with reaction foxnews contributor former
congressman trey Gowdy mr. Gowdy I
actually am very impressed I've always
known you were a prosecutor that never
lost a case and as I read parts of these
6,000 pages I'm a little tired I need
sleep and I'm even cranky tonight but I
see that you grilled Andrew McCabe at
what point did the bureau a steal why
did you do this research who were you
doing it for is anyone paying you to do
it when did those questions came up well
his answer trey Gowdy am I reading this
correctly the answer to your question is
I don't know the answer to that is that
possible at this point did that really
happen yeah it happened we spent a long
time with Andy McCabe the the dossier
not only was it not verified they had
not even begun to verify it when we
talked to and became but it was after it
was used now granted they used it in a
court proceeding any any pleading but
they had not even taken the first step
towards trying to verify that when we
interviewed Andy became you know Shawn
and listening to your monologue it
wasn't just that we asked Susan Rice and
Samantha power and Ben Rhodes and Sally
Yates we didn't just say give us all the
evidence of collusion coordination and
conspiracy I asked every one of them
even if it's hearsay even if it's
something you heard that you didn't
believe even if it's inadmissible in
court
tell me everything you've ever heard
about Trump his campaign or even the
groupies and the hangers-on in his
campaign conspiring with Russia there
was nothing so my expectations of Adam
Schiff are very low he still doesn't
meet him but they're very low my
invitations of the DC media was a little
bit higher and they aided and abetted
him for the entire year we conducted
this investigation this they'd nearly
succeeded trey Gowdy this is an
attempted coup he knew he was lying I
mean those people that he's interviewing
that you're interviewing under oath why
is it he held to the same standard I
also see you got McCabe told you that
they didn't have any evidence tying
Papadopoulos to Russia
he said the unverified dossier if they
didn't have
they wouldn't get the FISA application
you asked Samantha power about her role
as UN ambassador and and what would it
for example be the same as ambassador
Rice's why did she unmask all of these
people because you called her the
largest on mascar in US history did you
get any good answers we'll keep him up
on the screen as we get you did have why
did she love me I'll tell you Samantha
Power's explanation ought to scare the
hell out of you Shawn which is she said
I didn't make those unmasking requests
somebody on my team may have made them
but I did make them I mean keep in mind
somebody unmask Michael Flynn's name
somebody unmasked his name and then gave
that to President Obama I wouldn't Sally
Yates she didn't know anything about it
so I'd love for the DC media who loves
leaks they live on leaks I wish somebody
would leak to them who it was that told
President Obama that Michael Flynn's
name was in that transcript did anyone
that you interviewed and I every I was
looking for your interrogation you did a
great job behind the scenes a lot of
people did a great job behind the scenes
at any point did anybody in any way
shape man or a form ever confirm
anything in the dirty dossier that
Hillary paid for that Chris Christopher
steel sub source in February 2017 said
was wrong but still was used in a scope
memo by Rod Rosenstein in August of 2017
like eight months later and still used
to as a as a basis for the FISA warrants
the two remaining renewal warrants did
anyone ever give you any justification
to believe there was any truth in that
30 dossier that Hillary paid for sir
Glenn Simpson couldn't even do it and he
he's a fusion GPS owner Michael Cohen
who who hates the president he said the
dossiers just a bunch of lies I mean
this is somebody who hates Trump and he
said it's a bunch of Lies Glynn Simpson
bought and paid for and he couldn't
verify it I cannot believe the United
States trey Gowdy realize you're one of
the great pieces you will never lost the
case as a prosecutor I would argue this
is a clear and present danger to the
United States that a lying dossier that
was not verified was used to take away a
guy's constitutional rights spy on a
presidential candidate transition team
deep into the presidency and they all
knew it was a lie trey Gowdy how can
that happen in the great country the
United States of America with our US
Constitution can you explain that yeah
there are three groups that provide
accountability in this country there
there there's the voters they have a
chance to say whether or not Adam Schiff
reflects their values or sois well or
anyone else who perpetrated this fraud
there's the media and they totally
abdicated their role and then there's
the executive branch unfortunately we're
waiting on John Durham because the media
not only did they not provide scrutiny
over Adam Schiff they aided and abetted
him Politico the hill Washington Post
New York Times I'll come on even give
you the reporter's name sometime the
reporters who sat there and helped Adams
ship perpetrate this fraud
next time I'm with you I'll give you the
names of the reporters but we know he
knew the truth can he be held
accountable legally in any way that you
can think of you're a great attorney
no he's got immunity I mean he's sitting
there acting but the only accountability
shouldn't come from court let the voters
throw him out they could do better in
California all right
you did a great job behind the scenes as
to Devon newness and I don't I can't
even name everybody trey Gowdy thank you